[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
here we're heading we'll see how we
we'll see how we do it last episode
honestly went really really really hard
in
the paint i don't like to say that
really it's kind of okay to say but i
said it and uh said it and forget it
remember that infomercial the [ __ ]
guy the ron popeil guy who would do the
dried meat and he would just put it in
the thing and he'd be like set it and
forget it and they didn't add the part
afterwards which was like which was and
your house burns down can't forget it
you obviously have to turn it off dude
you can't forget it that's literally
false advertising you can't forget that
you have meats in the oven
okay
i got an air fryer so i [ __ ] dude i
leveled the [ __ ] up
pizza
even chicken dude we put a [ __ ] raw
chicken in that air fryer and
and cooked it up dude that it was so
and i don't do this i don't like to
switch languages but delicioso
um
air fryers are legit man
go ahead and reheat go ahead and reheat
pizza in the microwave go ahead go ahead
you [ __ ] plebian
daddy does it with an air fryer all day
long it's like he just ordered the pizza
hey did domino show up this is me my
pizza after i [ __ ] oh oh domino's
just must have shown up
last time i got domino's the guy said
dinner and i said yeah it's a little
late he showed up at my door said dinner
i said yeah it's a little late but yeah
not meaning not that domino's was too
late but meaning that
it was late for me to eat dinner and he
said it's never too late for domino's
and left and i was like oh my god how
[ __ ] happy can you be how happy can
you be
to be delivering anything and i don't
even mean as your job but just to be
walking over to someone and passing them
something and to be happy i aspire to
that level of [ __ ]
just i mean just
you know life's about just
i was thinking you know i was looking at
this [ __ ] um
10 comics to watch thing that variety
does uh for uh montreal and i was
looking at that the other day i had this
picture of it with a bunch of us on it
and a bunch of the people made it a
bunch of the people didn't now they all
kind of made it in their own way but one
of the one of them in my class passed
away i mean just life took a different
life was
and i was thinking about like wow it's a
trip to even look at that now
and it's not bad it's just different
like the excitement of making it as a
comedian i had it right there and i was
happy for that and excited for that and
i just don't feel that anymore and
that's because you know i've made it and
life is about different things now you
know my career was my most important
thing in my life and it's just not
anymore my family is and
you know uh
so yeah so anyway dude get a [ __ ] air
fryer if you want that pizza and um
and we got uh
the new merch out which we came out with
it last week we got the life rips the
blue colorway we have all the different
colorways everyone we need we ninja
turtles what are we the [ __ ] ninja
turtles we came out with the blue oh god
damn it we came out with the blue what
are we [ __ ] ninja what are we [ __ ]
ninja turtles we got orange and gr and
blue and purple and we got the [ __ ]
uh round
what are the
dude are you saying cowabunga when you
wear this [ __ ] and we got the uh this
and we got the um so go to
crystallia.com we got the hoodie i was
gonna wear it but dude it's way too
[ __ ] it's way too stinking hot in
here and you know it it's way too hot in
here um
yeah so uh
so that so yeah i got an air fryer and i
leveled up the game dude you got to get
an air fryer man for real i got it for
christmas my friend gave it to me and it
was a great useful gift man i'm all
about useful gifts you know i'm all
about useful gifts like we're building a
house right now and it's like we gotta
you know kristen's always like oh
wouldn't it be nice and i'm like well
what are we gonna [ __ ] use it for
right and she's like no it's just for
the vibe and i'm like the vibe is i want
to use it
right
so we have a little indoor outdoor area
that's good
for the summertime and we also live in
los angeles and i get to use that
open or closed i get double uses and i'm
all about double uses right i'm all
about double uses i use the air fryer
for [ __ ] pizza and chicken i mean i'm
it's crazy i go bonkers with that [ __ ]
anyway
um
so yeah dude um so sh so uh
so i don't even remember what the [ __ ] i
was talking about before the house but
uh
yeah we're building a house i've said it
before on the thing and uh we're in the
wii stages and they're just trying to
like
it's gonna take like years calvin's
gonna be [ __ ] 25 before the house is
even done but whatever
uh it's all good and um
you can sign up on our patreon
patreon.comcrystallia
and also like and subscribe it really
helps the algorithm and it gets this
this that's the thing dude if you're
about this [ __ ] cult life if you're
if you want to be in the log cabin with
us and our and the with with uh with the
babies [ __ ] sitting in high grass
sharing ideas then uh then then then
share like and subscribe and make
friends in the comments like always do
it
um
and support the show crystallia.com
that's we get the merch anyway dude
uh i was at coffee today and um you know
how i do it i always do that and what
did i get [ __ ]
iced americano dry said it and forget it
oh that's what i was talking about set
it and forget it dude infomercials are
crazy with the black and white [ __ ]
red x over the thing that you're not
supposed to do no
tired of regular knives
[ __ ] black and white person just
just [ __ ] stabbing themselves right
below the jaw none of that
um
and then a guy comes in with this new
knife you'll never stab your jaw wow set
it and forget it yay
dude
um so um
yeah man uh i was at the coffee shop
today and i got that americano i sat
down i was like what the hell am i going
to talk about in this podcast um and uh
some
lady came in with like neon green hair
so already i'm like
i'm out you know i'm out dude are you
excuse me ma'am ma'am
excuse me sorry to bother you are you an
nft
hey man with the [ __ ] jagged haircut
like you're in uh [ __ ]
like like you're like you're in the
matrix but they wouldn't let you win
because you're you're too [ __ ]
happy
you know it's she looked like [ __ ]
rainbow bright in 2022 now
and ma'am excuse me ma'am
i have a question are you dogecoin
what's going on excuse me ma'am
is this the metaverse no
then shave it and dye it back
okay
it's like not even it's like you you had
the kind of it was kind of the karen
haircut but it was like
also what's the movie with [ __ ] uh
chris tucker and the fifth element it
was like the fifth element karen the
fifth in the fifth it was like karen in
the fifth element
and it was just neon green and she was
just getting coffee like a person with
brown hair
that's the thing dude if you got
all of this [ __ ] and i mean all of this
[ __ ] like nose ring alternative
lifestyle your tongue is split
and
and the green hair and it's karen
you got to go to the coffee shop that's
like have a [ __ ] be in the meadowver
you want to be a [ __ ]
ethereum so bad you know what i mean go
get coffee on the [ __ ] blockchain be
fake drinking it
right
be fake drinking your [ __ ] macchiato
on a blockchain okay
karen 3000
it's like um so she's there and already
everyone is just like oh [ __ ]
checking the back of their necks for
that plug-in oh
hold up okay no this is real coffee bean
cool
and um
i drink the coffee it feels real okay
are we on the blockchain ma'am
and uh so
and and as if that's not enough and this
is i didn't mean to talk about all this
metaversion but this was the thing that
she was doing dude there's always music
playing in a coffee shop unless it's
green blatz which [ __ ] closed down
and was next to the laugh factory and
greenblatt was this diner that we
it was unfair what this [ __ ] diner
did to us dude it was next to the laugh
after i used to go all the time and i
used to get that [ __ ] reuben sandwich
with turkey pastrami and one time first
of all they brought it and they brought
turkey and pastrami and i [ __ ] up dude
i realized that's my fault because i
didn't say took a pastrami i said can i
get turkey pastrami and that's too slow
to say that
okay
it's tooth and that's and that's me
that's my fault so when they brought it
guess what i did i ate some of it and
then didn't eat the rest and i didn't
send it back because i [ __ ] up there's
rules and i didn't go by them and the
unspoken rules are the more important
rules because that shows that you get it
if you abide by the unspoken rules you
get it dude you're in
our matrix right
and we got our own karens
right like i get you can't rob and steal
i don't do that but those rules are
written
but when you say turkey pastrami and not
turkey pastrami and you get back turkey
and pastrami
you failed
okay
so now when i order that [ __ ] i run it
together i'm like the micro machines man
dude i'm like turquoise ramen can i get
a turkey pastrami sandwich
and they say oh sure and if they don't
look impressed with how fast i said it i
say
you know i meant turkey pastrami and not
turkey and pastrami right
and they say oh yeah
so we win [ __ ] we win
right
i got my own nft [ __ ] in our matrix in
our metaverse
and i know the unspoken rules
so um
what this greenblatt did was and they
got real nuts with it do it and i didn't
even know it was like there's this video
game i was watching the other day on
youtube and they uploaded this thing and
i was watching this level i didn't
remember what the hell it was but the
level started and it was like this i
didn't even realize but halfway through
there was this low-grade music and then
by the time the guy got to the boss of
the of that level
it was the boss that was playing
the the boss that you were fighting was
actually playing this organ
and that was where the low-grade music
was coming from all along and i was like
dude not only did i not even really
understand that there was a guy playing
an organ throughout this whole video
game i didn't even really understand
there was music playing it drifted in
and now i gotta fight this guy right
i felt had but
greenblatt i would go years and years
and then one day all of a sudden my
buddy
um
who is an animator
and just kind of not in the comedian
life he wasn't hooked into our world
um
he just said know what's weird about
greenblatt while we were eating there
and i said what and he said they don't
play music
and i never realized i have never been
to a [ __ ] diner or a deli that just
didn't have some sort of [ __ ]
do you know
[ __ ] jack johnson playing or even
like
enya or [ __ ] what's her name uh
what's your [ __ ] katy perry like they
play something right you're eating a
sandwich you don't even realize you're
eating it to the beat you know you're
like you're you're eating a [ __ ]
burrito and you're like why am i [ __ ]
oh i'm eating to the beat of the [ __ ]
lovely lady lumps or whatever the [ __ ]
the song is from black eyed peas
but
had us dude we were eating and it was
like what is going on and i realized
once once he said they don't play music
every time i went in i was like man this
is so weird dude can you put on some
lovely lady lumps please
i'll have the black eyed peas and also
play the black eyed peas
er worst joke ever and so um and this is
the reason why i bring it up this is the
reason why i bring up this whole thing i
know i got sidetracked into [ __ ]
there were many tentacles in this
conversation and many tentacles in this
story and let's just get back to the
[ __ ] squid right we'll get back to
the squid
all right we're all the arms of the
squad i went off i started talking about
an air fryer i went off i started
talking about nfts i went off i started
talking about the fifth element and all
the other things this the music at
greenblatt but let's get back to the
squid
all right
let's get back to that beak part of the
squid did you even know that the squid
has a beak part did you know that a
squid has a [ __ ] beak straight up did
you know that
squids have beaks man and we're just
supposed to be out here living our lives
right somebody invented the internet and
a [ __ ] toaster and we forgot all
about squid beaks dude
squid there's a beak and they shoot out
they wrap you up and they shoot out and
they beat you the [ __ ] up in your chest
that's how steve irwin died i think
maybe
you know what i mean they got beaks dude
[ __ ] underwater they got beaks dude
i didn't know that
they're wet birds in there dude just not
flying just beaking it up man
pulling you in french kissing you
[ __ ] making your [ __ ] all [ __ ] up
making your [ __ ] all lumpy making your
[ __ ] like ground beef with their [ __ ]
beak
just [ __ ] great you ever see the end
of that [ __ ] uh prometheus or
whatever the [ __ ] movie is where they
were that big ass tall white guy that's
secretly black dude when they made that
movie prometheus with the [ __ ] guy in
it michael fassbender or whatever which
is a made-up name fast bender but dude
when when when they
at the end when the alien comes out
because he's been cooking for the whole
time in the lab and he comes out and he
grabs that big-ass albino white black
dude dude they tried to make it so that
do you have you seen that movie you know
what i'm talking about the big-ass white
duties in the beginning and the end of
the movie because in the beginning of
the movie and then we go we'll see how
he was [ __ ] made or whatever
the prometheus movie it was that from
the aliens thing
from the aliens uh
quadruply trilogy how many alien movies
are there [ __ ] ten of them anyway
there's this big ass duty just literally
straight up looks like [ __ ] michael
jordan it's so racist so they were like
we got to make him completely albino you
know he was an albino in the beginning
but they were like dude he looks like a
black guy they're going to come for us
the woke mob's going to come for us we
got to make them white and they just
kept making them whiter and whiter and
whiter until he was [ __ ] translucent
and they were like this is basically it
anyway when that [ __ ] at the end when
the alien comes in and they pull him in
the guy the white dude is extra strong
because he's an alien but that [ __ ]
alien comes in with the tentacles and
brings them in all into his [ __ ]
mouth [ __ ] and beaks him up dude
so that's what i'm saying let's get back
to that beak
what were we talking about though what
even was the [ __ ] thing i was saying
i was talking about the lady dancing the
reason why i was talking about this
whole thing about the [ __ ] thing that
happened at coffee bean is because all
of a sudden this fifth element nft style
girl with the karen haircut from [ __ ]
rainbow brite dude she starts uh dancing
in the cafe she starts dancing to the
music and i don't know what they're
playing but she's [ __ ] bopping and
dude i i thought about talking about
this on the podcast and whenever i
brought it up
in my head to me while driving or
whatever the [ __ ] in the living room
i thought well i'm not gonna do the
dancing
because it
it makes me insecure even by myself
do you know what i'm talking about
people are out there doing [ __ ] that
makes
me insecure not even doing it for people
but by myself and they're out there
doing it
like we're paying them to
right
have you ever been out at a place like a
diner i was at a mel's diner
once
and busta rhymes was there
but not being bust to rhymes just eating
a sandwich
he was being whatever his regular name
is mr rhymes [ __ ] jack rhymes i don't
know what his regular name is
but
busta was just sitting there eating
something at mel's diner and all of a
sudden a lady comes up to him and just
starts singing
like she's going to put his like he's
going to put his [ __ ] turkey pastrami
[ __ ] down
sorry took her swami [ __ ] down
and all of a sudden just be like hold up
be on the third track on my next album
it's just not gonna happen but people
are but she did it she's saying like we
were paying her for it when in actuality
that's not the world we're in right now
right
we're in eating world
we're in the
mel's metaverse
right
all these different [ __ ]
it's like
figure out where we are
and be that way
there's dance clubs hey man
hi i don't mean to bug you and i touched
you in real life so apparently you're
not an nft but uh there's dance clubs
for that all right take care but the
what the dancing she was doing was
and i don't even want to do it alone and
i'm alone now but you guys are going to
see this but this is what the dancing
she was doing she was going like this
like this ah [ __ ] it's cringy right
and i'm doing it and if you're just
listening thank you by the way if you're
watching i'm sorry and if you're
listening thank you and you're welcome
but she was doing it like this
like like she had two small [ __ ] right
like this like just jerking them
and she was doing it like this and then
leaning her head back a little bit
jerking to [ __ ] and leaning her head
back what making the two guys [ __ ]
jizz on each other not her right that's
what was happening because when you're
[ __ ] leaning back and you're doing
that
you're jerking
they [ __ ] splash on each other's
right
they [ __ ] sp whoopsie you spunk down
this tip that's what they do
not me though and you lean back with it
right
and so she was leaning back with her
doing the dancing and then she stopped
and then she did the dancing again and
hey i'm just like lady but be in line
though hey just be in line it's one
thing to have all the outfit
and then it's another thing to also amp
it up with doing all the dancing that
you should be doing in a dance club
and that's all i honestly have to say
about that many many tentacles but we
got to the beak
it's just dude
maybe i'm jealous because she was so
carefree right
i think that's the hottest thing a
person can be as carefree i think it's
the sexiest hottest thing a person can
be as carefree
right that's why pete davidson is like
the [ __ ] man get dating everybody
he's dating [ __ ] what's her name
mother teresa next and she's dead dude
and he just cause he's so carefree he's
just like if you ask pete what's up he'd
be like ah man
whatever
hey but we're at war ah man [ __ ] dude
do you want this what is that i don't
it's a i found it what is it it's a
thing i just found well what is it i
don't really know but you want it you're
like oh god all right let's [ __ ] like
that's how carefree is the [ __ ] girls
are guys
why doesn't it matter though that that
speaks to my soul but why doesn't it
matter when something doesn't matter to
somebody
i feel less than
and um
and that's how they [ __ ] and we all need
more of that especially if we want to
[ __ ]
be sexy right that's what we're all
striving to be sexy in a coffee shop
[Music]
so uh
yeah man i love it i love it and by the
way dude i know i come hard
in the uh
podcast i know i come hard with it
sometimes and you guys are like he's a
curmudgeon but i'm not though because i
want that lady to do what she does
above all else do what you do and dress
how you want above all else but also i
get to complain and have a good time
with it
right
those guys out there with [ __ ] ascots
that's way worse
are those [ __ ] what are those like
remember those taliban scarves that
everybody used to wear like for nine
months
um
i [ __ ] i did the king in the sting
it's out if you can go watch out i did
king of this thing i was with eric
uh
griffin and brendan schaub and uh i
filled in a little bit because i know
theo couldn't be there but i was the
guest on the couch
um
and uh that was good we talked you know
they got a good they got a good show
there um i i had never watched
a full episode obviously i've seen clips
but uh i saw the uh
i saw the whole episode that i was in
because uh but i saw it through my own
eyes when i was there i didn't watch it
um
so you can check that out
i've been doing a lot of watching though
a lot of watching i think you know what
i did the other day i turned on regular
tv i have that i didn't even know
flipped the channel and it was like
a 8 30 or something and every channel
was about like
was about like black people trying to be
a musician or an artist or something and
it was like
yeah it was like the networks were
trying so hard to not be racist but also
being racist dude
like
they're hiring i know they're hiring
people of color to do the people of
color shows right
is the guy at the head still like
some white jewish guy like why is this
happening like i turned on that show
blackage blackit black itch wow going to
[ __ ] hell i turned on this show
blackish and the lead guy his name is
dre
like dude
first of all i thought it was drake and
i i fell out of my chair i thought it
was drake i thought the guy's name was
drake and then i and then realized it
was dre but also that's still like such
a big hip-hop guy
like don't name him that
it's i mean i get okay people of color i
hope they were in charge of this is all
i'm saying and i know they are because i
know that guy kenya barris did the show
or whatever but i hope what he said goes
because i just imagine this white dude
like at the top that's just like
can we call him dre
do you know what i mean
can we call him is it cool if we leave
everything but we call him dre and
they're like well i just
i like his name
richard yeah but
i don't know i just like dre
just not explaining himself some white
jewish guy yeah just like dre
because this was before probably this
show was on the air before kenya barrows
was kinder bear is that even his name or
am i being racist
kenya you know
um
it's like a [ __ ] my name was denmark
denmark dalia uh
[ __ ] north pole johnson
uh
so
for [ __ ] sake dude
what's a really white place spokane
spokane johnson um so uh
so every and then i change the channel
and i know that [ __ ] that
i turn on the show queen queens with
brandy
who is i think brandy by the way is
there's something about brandy that is
the most attractive thing i think brandy
it's so funny too because you like i
looked it up on imdb to see what the
[ __ ] actors and the characters names
were and it's so funny that on imdb
they'll be like it'll be like brandy and
then her last name too and it's like oh
okay it's all official now right
like [ __ ] it'll be like ella cool j
is in this but also it's james todd
smith and you're like oh oh
oh
okay
right
and uh so
so i'm watching this [ __ ] show queens
and it was about
the r b rap
[ __ ] world and i'm just like all
right
it was just so funny to me that these
[ __ ] networks are like
just
trying so hard
and i'm not saying it's a bad thing it's
a hilarious thing
because like i i i they don't care they
just act like they care because they
think their money is affected right
and so they make this show called queens
and
brandy's in it and the [ __ ]
two artists
that they're
that are in the show
are
lady zee
and explicit
hey
name them better
hey uh
try a little bit more
did you give up
halfway through thinking
lady z
and explicit
why don't you just call one of them
break
dude lady z
[Music]
but there's but there's jay-z though
[Laughter]
oh but there's exhibit explicit
hello and what meet your archrivals
break and bust the crimes
[Laughter]
and foxy drowned dude
try harder i'm sure people of color
wrote this
so stop being so white people of color
dude it's insane man
it's insane dude explicit dude
x to the t
it was oh and you oh and you better
believe it was axe
split it wasn't ex dude
oh yeah and we uh yeah hey what up i'm
i'm this is your rapper explicit and i
got a show on vh1 pimp my pride
try think
further
dude it's like this whole thing was
thrown into an algorithm and it just
fired it out the back end
people running these shows
what what is going on
what what
is going on and people are watching it
look at these are the rest of the names
eve plays prof
professor sex that's her rap name in it
that's what it says
jill the thrill at least those aren't
lil muffin i mean
these would be but dude it's just like
on it's like
and dude they're saying [ __ ] like yeah
and it's lit and dude these people are
40 in it brandy's older than me you know
yeah i'm in the hizzy like what dude
who's writing this [ __ ]
like just that's that's why it's like
just do you abc just do what you're
doing you don't have to try to do what
you think you should do
because it's [ __ ] it's that lady
dancing in the coffee bean it's it's
embarrassing dude
a cringe city
it's like so weird man
it's it i i kept flipping the channel it
was it kept being about [ __ ] hip-hop
producers dude
oh my god dude
it was [ __ ] hilarious
and everything is is turning into that
too it's like
it's so weird
this is [ __ ] so weird man
and i'm not saying don't ha like this is
i could so see somebody saying oh
crystal making fun of [ __ ] oh black
people shouldn't be on tv like you're a
[ __ ] idiot if you think that's what
i'm saying you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's not what i'm saying
but like can't like god
god you know what dude it's like and
then and then they go on the other end
and they do the [ __ ] what's that
movie the the movie with the [ __ ] all
the black cowboys and [ __ ]
on netflix and it's like okay
never mind then they tried to make black
people white
too and also it didn't work it's like
just
but of course everyone's reviewing that
somebody said the best cast imaginable
dude i love how i saw that billboard
what's it called the harder they fall is
it that [ __ ] movie and they're like
best cast imagine dude that's the thing
that they're running with best cast
imaginable and in my head i'm like oh
but
jiminy cricket and jesus christ i these
are what do you mean imaginable
gregory peck he's dead though
sidney poitier just died i'm imagining
him though
oh cool you got some guy that was in
some movies
i'm imagining napoleon bonaparte though
best case imaginable
it at best best cast alive
but also no though
whatever dude i'm too [ __ ]
whatever bro it's like dude it's just
like
[ __ ] lady z dude
there's like
even with the z dude
um
speaking of rappers kodak black did that
thing where he had sex in the [ __ ]
box seat
what is
kodak black you know like he
i feel like when he goes to a place
he doesn't walk he just says okay and
just [ __ ]
rolls
what shape is he
what
is he five tires like what
what it what is what is going on dude
he is a simpson
right like if you saw him walk by homer
in the show the simpsons you wouldn't
even think about it but in real life
you go oh there are my tires
are you just [ __ ] four trash bags
like what's what are you
who is
what is going on dude
i listened to an interview with him and
he it was so
all was unbelievable dude he was just
like you know
what i don't even know but you know what
i mean you know you're talking a minute
that's
and then somebody would be like [ __ ] you
you don't even get this lifestyle
what lifestyle
the i don't
the i don't hear you lifestyle
i you know and like about being
okay like oh yeah you're just you're old
you don't get it that's my favorite
thing you're old you don't get it no
what though
that's why i think that people need to
to be
somebody in society you'd nee you need
you don't need to actually do but you
need to be able to do more than one job
you can have one job
right as a matter of fact you should
only have one job and do everything for
that one job but you need to be able to
do two jobs
different jobs if you can't
you gotta just kind of plug in and be in
the metaverse you can't be walking
around
like what else the [ __ ] could kodak
black do right
do you know what i mean like some day
trip some some [ __ ] wall street guys
you're like oh all you could do is do
this [ __ ] dude get out get go in a
metaverse with kodak black i'm not it's
not a
you know what i mean
we just wore the ski mask and the
[ __ ] branch camouflage at the morning
show
or whatever the hell that see the god
show is
that's the level of camouflage i need to
get though when they started doing the
branch camouflage i got boots with the
branch camouflage on it dude [ __ ] leaves
i got branches on that [ __ ]
that's the level of camouflage
but man it's so funny man
i don't know what interview it was but
they were like and the interviewer was
like what do you mean though and he was
like
me
let me say that's what i'm saying
people under it what did he say next guy
under that you're just saying about that
life
guess not dude
guess i'm about a different life
[Laughter]
you know
i love that you're old bro you don't get
it
yeah yo
i love that [ __ ] where it's like oh dude
he's that's my favorite thing dude not
like when i post a [ __ ] video one of
the things is like oh man dude what's
this guy know he's in his 40s or what is
he 45 or 50 and it's like dude how is
that a dis
it's good to get old you did it
you made it
some people
die first
that's worse
right
i don't want to be dying i want to be
living i want to keep living 80 90 100.
i want to keep going oh yeah but that
dude's old i guess people don't really
do it when they're like in their 70s or
80s it's mostly 40 to like 55 people are
like you old [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and you're like this is just the middle
can i just chill
this is just the middle of my life dude
hey can you relax stop [ __ ] busting
on me and let me be 40.
40's the [ __ ] though really
god you're ne people are the funniest
when they when they're in their 40 for
real dude
like imagine a [ __ ] 20 year old chip
tripping
imagine a 30 year old tripping okay fine
could be funny 40 year old tripping
forget it dude you pack up i got to sit
the [ __ ] down i'm laughing for a long
time 50 year old also funny not as fun
as 40 because that's when the sadness
creeps in
because that's what
is he going to break a hip hit you know
what i mean 60 no if you 70 if you're
laughing summer falls you're [ __ ]
you're you're satan
you can't laugh at a 70 and up guy
falling 40 that's it a little bit fat
that's it
a 40 a little bit fat not even fat but
like big guy who would be like nah it's
just a i'm big bone like a guy who would
be like a big bone and also like gets
pink when he starts running a little bit
and he falls and has fluffy hair forget
it dude forget it
that's the end of the week whatever day
that happens even if it's monday that's
the end of the week let's start again
monday here we go
unbelievable dude
but we talk real [ __ ]
but we're talking about [ __ ]
um
[Music]
yeah but so kodak black did sex in a box
seat and then everyone put the internet
video but the video on the internet from
across the way and then they shot
somebody shot video in inside the box
and he wasn't actually doing it but it
looked like he was doing it doggy style
or whatever the [ __ ]
five tires style and um
and uh then he was just kind of like
bouncing on her instead of not doing it
instead of doing a doggy style and the
word got out but i guess apparently
twitter blew up about it i don't know
but the internet was going nuts about
how hey kodak black is having sex with
the girl in the box seat and it wasn't
happening so that's the thing kodak you
got us again you got us once again you
had america you got we got had huh
um
so yeah so i did uh
so i've been watching a lot of tv i
watched the shark tank thing i can't
stop watching shark tank
shark tank is one of those shows that
[ __ ] pisses me off as much as it does
about how good it is
it's a good show it's so watchable and
it's so easily consu you could just
consume the [ __ ] out of it it's like
eating bacon you're just like yeah but
maybe one more
you know what i mean
it's like it's like if i could put two
shark tank episodes on at once and watch
them both and have my eyes be like that
[ __ ] uh
that weird guy in the frankenstein
movies i'd watch both
um
and uh
i just [ __ ] that hold in my head all
day long i've been watching it for like
a week and a half and
[Music]
craig believes he can
revolutionize
it's always like some small ass idea
that we're like oh [ __ ]
craig revolutionized drinking alcohol
it's a belt loop that converts into a
cup holder young thing
wrong
all right craig what are you looking for
mr wonderful because remember money
doesn't money doesn't sleep just already
with a coined thing the thing i love
about money is it's not your girlfriend
okay
the thing i love about young the thing i
love about money is you know what i love
about money it has more hair than me
craig's looking for a steak 50 for 50
billion dollars for for [ __ ] for a
[ __ ] ring
hi i'm craig hello sharks i'm craig and
i would i'm looking for a 30 stake in my
50 company and i would like 12 12
and what happens is yeah sure there's
[ __ ] rings out there but not like this
let me show you what you do is you take
the ring and you unplug it and then you
put it in your balls right above your
shaft and there we go oop and there we
go oh ahaha you know what i like about
[ __ ] rings it's not just
wrong and then the sharks the
hammerheads swimming over the [ __ ]
building when we come back where are we
so he offered damon offered [ __ ]
[ __ ] rings is not necessarily a business
i want to get into so for that reason
one time when i was younger i used a
[ __ ] ring and it caught and there was a
lot of blood so for that reason i'm out
tired of regular [ __ ] hi i'm or it's
always like some hi i'm the one the ones
i don't get it at all
are the [ __ ] clothing lines who's
investing like it's just another
clothing line
and then like the girls will always try
to back door it in you know they're like
so
hi it's lisa
she
lisa and tammy are looking for a 20
stake in their company pregnant ladies
shirts
ding ding hi hi sharks
i'm lisa and then tammy and i'm tammy
and today we're launching pregnant
church together
and there's always that one dude that's
real creative with it so here's what
i'll do i'll give you a seven times what
you ask but but can i put the shirts in
my anus
[Music]
okay so here's what i'm gonna do you're
asking for 30 grand i'm gonna give you
15 million dollars can i eat the shirts
and will you wait here until i [ __ ] them
out
then then sharks over the building and
then they come back
sharks over the building
so can i eat the shirts and will you
wait do we gotta do the recap you know
like we're not we're idiots not watching
first of all everyone's watching it on
hulu and if they're not we remember
there were two [ __ ] charming
commercials before i [ __ ]
so two sharks are out because they're
just [ __ ] t-shirts and these ladies
are trying to backdoor it in by using
pregnancy
when i was pregnant i noticed that there
were shirts but none of them would fit
yeah so what we did is we designed a
shirt that's a little bit fatter in the
[ __ ] belly
do you have any sales no
well okay how is it a business i made
shirts though
yum
[Applause]
[ __ ] mr wonderful eating shirts
trying to [ __ ] him out
you know what i love about these shirts
they don't give you a stomachache
but that's a great thing about fabric
you can [ __ ] it out in three in under
three hours it's like going it's like
you eat a shirt you go to vegas you get
there you use the toilet
you don't even have to stop dang think
you shouldn't have fabric in the mirage
you can [ __ ] out a whole shirt by the
time you get to excalibur yeah
[Applause]
you're on the roller coaster new york
new york and you're putting out a
[ __ ] cape
mr wonderful on a [ __ ] on the new
york new york roller coaster [ __ ]
out a [ __ ] pregnancy shirt a
pregnancy shirt on the back end
screaming out i invested 14 million
dollars dude and that's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] i am talking about
i want to get on that i want to get on
that show why is kevin hart on it hey
kevin hart you're done pack up you did
it you're done why are you hey kevin
hart spend time with your kids why are
you on shark tank dude
what's going on
you know [ __ ] kevin hart did shark
tank and the rock was like some [ __ ]
beat me to it you know you know a
hundred percent
so pissed off with the eyebrow up at
home god damn it in his tank top just
sweating profusely on the couch
after [ __ ]
talking about hawaii too much
you know
um
after talking about mana or whatever it
is by the way how what's the over under
how long do you think until [ __ ] uh
the rock comes out with an energy drink
or a power drink that and it's called
like mana energy or some [ __ ] how how
long how long do you think how did it
not happen yet
what's mata is mana the thing
you don't know
wow he doesn't know what i'm talking
about now now this is the thing
i think that's the mana is the hawaiian
meaning what is mana here look in some
polynesian languages the literal meaning
of man of mana is thunder storm or wind
yeah dude how is there how has the rock
when
is the rock gonna come out with a mana
energy drink because that's happening
anyway
uh kevin hart's on [ __ ] shark tank
and that's hilarious so uh you know what
they say about that
so uh
i want to be on shark tank
i don't just every every time they come
in i i don't have
the money i i don't have the same amount
of money you guys have i think maybe
yeah maybe i'm out
yeah
a sad one
ten ten ten
yen ten
i only i don't know i had a rough year
sales always uh drop at the end of the
month for me because it's patreon
[Music]
you know what i like about patreon
um
yeah dude so uh
what was i saying the [ __ ] thing
about those guys dude they have so much
[ __ ] money and then also i like how
the guy who doesn't invest much
he has 350 million everyone's a
billionaire except for the guy on the
end
and he's just like i only have 350
million dollars
he loses he loses
the [ __ ] one on the end with the
[ __ ] uh what do you call it the uh
the the the beaker that's the color of
his skin
i always know when somebody has a beaker
on their face you can't hide it just
because it's not brown
what the [ __ ] the birth beauty mark or
whatever the [ __ ]
if you're gonna have a beauty mark dude
if what i call them a beaker if you're
gonna have a beaker make the ship brown
dude don't make it clear those are the
worst the clear beakers
dude and i say beaker and i've been
saying this as a little kid because when
i was a little kid a beaker is a raised
beauty is a beauty mart it's like a
[ __ ] not a freckle it's raised what
do they call them [ __ ] what what
beauty mark is that what you call them
juan yeah beauty mark all right well i
call it a beaker and as a kid when i was
a kid
i just thought they were called beakers
like i just i don't know it was just
like it was already in my vocabulary i
never learned it nobody ever called it a
beaker i just called it a [ __ ] beaker
as a kid and i was talking about it with
my mom and i was like oh man my mom i
have so many beakers and she was like
what the [ __ ] is a what and i was like a
beaker and she's like what's a beaker
and i started pointing them on my arms
and she was like she started laughing
she was like you mean beauty mark and i
was like yeah beaker and she's like
where'd you learn that i don't know it
should be called a beaker dude and so
that's what it is so if you're gonna
have a beaker i hope it's brown man
a lot of people with those [ __ ]
translucent beakers out there get out of
here man
have a zit or a [ __ ] beaker don't
make that [ __ ] the same color as your
skin
i did a show i did a show with brendan
schaub and uh we did it in uh it was
brendan shaw befriends at the improv and
it was awesome here's the thing i was
watching um
i was in the what do you call it uh
i was i was
what am i trying to say
i had
i i did a podcast last week and in the
middle of my podcast kristen said she
was bringing calvin to a movie and that
i should come and i ended the podcast
and i had to get to the improv and i
couldn't make it i'm like babe i don't
want to do that and i'm upset because i
want to be there for calvin's first
movie and she was like well i'm with him
out and i never really get time to like
kind of like
de-stress and unwind so i'm just going
to go see the movie and i was like i
would really appreciate it if you don't
you can do anything else i want to be
there for my son's first movie and she
was like well we're already inside
anyway
i was like okay you know i don't want to
make a thing out of it
but i was upset
swallowed it and i um
and then i and then i i had to get ready
for the show and then i went to the to
the
uh get my coffee as i do i do my thing i
[ __ ] get in and i do my uh
i i do my routine you know i went to the
coffee bean i got the coffee actually i
think i went to the [ __ ] starbucks
even but i went to starbucks and i went
to the improv and when i went to the
improv i was uh you know i kind of was
thinking about my son watching move i
was like i hope he has a good time but i
was still kind of bummed out and i got
into the green room at the improv and i
hear tata and calvin's there
and i just everything just melts away
i'm not bummed out anymore i'm not upset
and kristen's a hero and he's just da da
da da da and he runs to me gives me a
big hug and calvin's in there and i
almost start crying and i i put it on my
other youtube channel uh more chris
uh more crystalia and it's uh on the
it's the pre-show with chris it's called
and um
my face even the side of my face you can
see like how emotional dude i [ __ ]
everything else felt fell away and it
was the first now instead of seeing my
son's first movie it was my first first
time my son was gonna see me on stage
and i was gonna be hanging out with him
in the green room with my other people
who still you know look it's been a
[ __ ]
weird two years for me to say the least
and the other comedians on the show that
were still [ __ ] rocking with me and
that that uh in the face of fear still
support me um
is just was such a beautiful thing man
and that
you know to think that my career used to
be the most important thing and now it's
not my family is the most important
thing and now i'm at this show and my
family's there in with two of now the
most important things
it was just too much for me to even
handle dude it was just so emotionally
uh amazing and i was nervous for like
the first time
in a long time besides the first time i
came i came back i started doing
stand-up i was a little nervous but dude
to have i was like calvin's not even two
and i'm nervous for this person to watch
me because i want him to [ __ ] like me
i want him to like me and it wasn't like
i want him to think i'm funny like he
doesn't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
saying
as a matter of fact i went on stage and
he was just like
that he was so confused and chris was
like she watched me for 30 seconds then
he was like trying to run around and she
was like be quiet be quiet and then just
put on something on the phone for him to
watch i'm like people buy pay tickets
for this [ __ ] i told him she should just
put my specials on that would have been
funny because no matter what if it's on
that phone he'll just zero in on it but
it was such a beautiful thing man you
can go watch that video on on the more
crystallia channel uh
the pre-show with chris
and uh
yeah it was just [ __ ] really wild and
i love it and i just loved that moment
man and i loved that moment
it's just so much it's so much feeling
you know
it's crazy to be a person
a period
actually
it's so much
if you let it be you know what i'm
talking about
like that's why i say life rips it's
like it it it's so
it's it really is a feeling of
what you let it be
right like i could have the old me would
have walked into that green room no i
didn't have a son right the old me the
the unaware
sleepwalking through life guy
what didn't have us it wasn't when i had
a son but the old me would have wouldn't
have necessarily stopped and thought
about that and taken that in i wouldn't
have allowed it because it was too much
feeling right i talk about how i don't
like
music a lot because it's artificially
making me feel these emotions and that's
what life was to me it was you're not
going to make me feel that way i choose
how i feel
but if you're doing that then how much
of the life are you living
right like nobody wants to be around all
day and cry at every [ __ ] waking
moment there's a lot of sadness in the
world but there's also a lot of
happiness and you need to feel all of
that to be a person if you're not then
you might as well be in the metaverse
and have a jerky [ __ ] foxhead
right
you might as well
because you're not really living
life is as much feeling as you let it be
and as much as you let it take in
because man having my son there in that
green room
having my son there knowing that he was
watching his dad
do his job
for him too you know
like i actually do it
it was the reason why i went back on
stage
it's because of him
i didn't
you know i checked out i was in a bad
[ __ ] place man i did not want to you
know there were
weeks and months at a time where i
didn't i was like [ __ ] it dude
so many people threw me on the under the
bus [ __ ] them i'm not doing stand-up
anymore that's not a community i'm not
in that community i don't want to be in
that community [ __ ] that i don't want to
be in that community
you know
the world has a certain uh uh opinion of
of of me or whoever the [ __ ] has an
opinion of me or whoever the [ __ ] it is
uh
you don't know who i am
and
there was a long time where i just
wanted to give up
and
the only thing
that made me
get back on stage at certain points was
my son's gonna be 20 one day or 15
whatever the [ __ ] it is of a mind to ask
me
oh hey dad you used to be a comedian
and i would have to say yeah and he
would say
well why don't
you do that anymore
and i'd
i'd have to say a version of
i let the world get the best of me
or
i let people say and believe that i'm
something that i'm not
and i gave up
and when it comes to my son
that's just not an option
um
so yeah
so that's what
that's what that means to me having him
there
and that's what that means to me having
him there with all the people
that i love
and still love
uh whether that be
you
know brendan schaab
theo
craig conan
chappelle lacy eric griffin you know and
i'm just naming some of them but
you know and my fiance and calvin who uh
who knows me
um
i love you [ __ ]
but that was a nice special day that i
had no idea was coming you know
sometimes you have special days because
you're ready and sometimes a special day
just hits you over the side of the
[ __ ] head
that's what that was
i didn't mean to get so heavy speaking
of heavy i want to talk about this about
uh bob saget man um
it was just
you know what the crazy thing about bob
saget first of all bob saget
he was
he was a great guy
i knew him a little um
always was smiles and
made you feel like when you're talking
to him he was
you were the you know one of those
people oh you oh okay this is bob saget
you know but when i was a younger
comedian he he treated me like a person
which doesn't always happen with uh
bigger comedians and
um
he
we we had a um a conversation once that
um where we disagreed about something
and i walked away
feeling
um
so
taken aback by how
he
how he handled it you know
um it was by no means an argument or
anything like that but it was just
it was something that i realized
afterwards if it were someone else and
if it was someone else with any sort of
agenda
it could have been such a weird thing
but he made it so
comfortable
by being
a great guy about it and it wasn't he
wasn't being a great guy he just was a
great guy he
it's so sad to see him go because
of that energy that he brought to the
world
um
you know whether it be
on tv
or
making you laugh or just
even if it wasn't bob saggy you he would
be one of those guys that would be in
the room and you'd be like oh that guy
oh yeah that guy oh i [ __ ] like that
guy like that's
that he radiated that really he really
did and
he was one of those guys too that like
it's gonna be a little bit weird to not
have him in the world like he's been
around ever since i could remember and
he was 65 which is young
and you just he seemed like a guy that
was just gonna be 95
you know and in 30 years you were going
to be like
that was
hey yeah bob saget had his run but he
died too early and
it's such a shame man
it really is
you know i didn't know him well but i
knew him and
i hope this is coming across the way i
wanted to because you just
i don't know i i just
i think it was a
special guys go i think he was a special
guy
he had a lot of friends and i've been
texting with a lot of them you know
reaching out saying oh hey i know this
is close to you i'm sorry
and uh yeah they're all saying how
horrible it is
you never heard a bad word about bob
saget
but um
anyway yeah
i don't know how long i've even done
this podcast
maybe i should do this one more thing
i'm gonna
total
oh jesus christ okay
well i guess we can i had that cool mo d
wrapper thing i could do that next time
actually that's a good thing to do next
time um all right well that's that we'll
end on that rest in peace bob saget
you were a legend you know
wow
you were a legend in only 65 years how
about we'll say that that's pretty
amazing
so that's that that's the podcast thanks
for listening if you want sign up on our
patreon and uh we really appreciate you
support the show if you do that we keep
on bringing the show and making the show
and you can go to crystallia.com for the
new life rips colorway and the go medium
and sometimes stay out or the sorry
strong guys merch and you help support
the show we love you join us on fl on
twitch flex avenue and subscribe and
like and also
leave comments for the algorithm make
make friends in the comments you see
somebody talking [ __ ] you make friends
you say let's go to red robin hey guys
that's the episode for today uh we are
uh done here on youtube if you want the
rest of the episode the extra epis the
extra
uncut version of it go to patreon that's
patreon.comcrystalia
there's a lot other uh of other stuff
there's an extra episode a month there's
also another segment we do called review
mode and uh we've got behind the scenes
stuff and we're actually adding some
stuff so uh go on over to
patreon.com crystallia no ads no
commercials anywhere and we'll see you
there
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
pam